SARAH: Kate Kerrigan is a New
York Times best-selling author
living and working in Ireland.
Her novels include international
bestseller "Recipes
for a Perfect Marriage," which
has been translated into 15
language, and the
"Irish-American Ellis Island
Trilogy."
Her latest novel "The Dress"
is published by Head of Zeus
this month.
So Kate is actually the
pen name of Morag Prunty.
Morag left school at 15,
worked in a hairdressing salon
for four years before entering
the world of women's magazines.
Went on to become
the youngest ever
person to edit a
national magazine
and an award winning
editor of iconic titles
as "More" and "Just
Seventeen" during which time
you helped launch the
career of "Take That,"
which is very interesting.
In 1991-- I'm sure we'll have
more questions about that,
but let's talk about the book.
In 1991, you walked
out of a media career
to fulfill a personal
ambition to move to Ireland,
where you became the
editor of "Irish Tattler."
During that tenure, Morag
began to write to fiction,
and then, in 2000, had
her first book published
under her own name,
"Dancing with Mules,"
which earned an unprecedented
advance from Pan
Macmillan in the UK and
Harper-Collins in the US.
In 2006, tired of
writing comedy,
Kate changed her style
of writing completely
to a more serious and emotional
tone and became Kate Kerrigan.
So I'm really interested to
hear about that change as well.
And in your new novel,
"The Dress, Kate
references her magazine
days with a dual timeline
story of a magnificent
[INAUDIBLE] gown
made in the 1950s
New York, which
is replicated by a young vintage
blogger in present day London.
So Kate's here today to
talk about her career
journey, including,
I have "Take That"
wearing S&M gear for
their first big gig,
working in magazines
before computers
and what it takes these days
to become a published author.
She will also hopefully
share some of her new novel
"The Dress" with us.
So thank you all.
KATE KERRIGAN: Thanks.
Thanks a million, Sarah.
And I don't know what
I'm going to say now.
I think that's just
about said it all.
Well, I was thinking
this morning, first, what
am I going to wear into Google?
You know?
What am I going to-- And then
what could I possibly talk
about to people that work
in this fascinating industry
about myself that would
be of any interest?
And so what I thought I'd do is
just run through my own career
and how I came to
become a writer.
Because it's a strange job.
When I tell people
that I'm a writer,
people always are just very
interested in that fact alone.
And the first thing they
usually say is, oh my god.
Where do you get
your ideas from?
How do you come up
with ideas for books?
They usually say that.
Or quite often they
also say, oh, I
would like to write a book,
but I just don't have the time.
But I've got this
greaty great idea,
and if I give it you, then
maybe you'll write it for me.
Which is just
surprising the number
of people that say that to me.
So I thought I'd just talk
a little bit about myself
if you like, and about my
background and my history,
if that's something
that's interesting.
And then maybe you can
just ask me some questions.
Then if we've got a
bit of time at the end,
maybe I might read you
a bit from the book
and put you through that.
Well just being here
in Google I suppose
is just making me think a
bit about my relationship
through my quite long
career with technology.
As Sarah was saying
in the instruction,
I left school at 15.
I did very, very
poorly in school.
I could not get on with--
no one seemed to be
able to teach me anything.
Something about either
the school that I went
to or the way that
my brain is wired,
I just quite simply cannot
take in information in any kind
of a conventional way, and I
went to a very conventional
school.
So I left there at
15 under the cloud--
the threat of my parents,
who were both schoolteachers,
saying to me if you don't
study hard in school,
you'll end working
sweeping up hair
in Keith Fisher's hair salon
on Brent Street and Hendon.
And that's exactly what I did.
That's exactly where I ended up.
And I actually started then four
quite jolly year hairdressing.
I rather enjoyed my
time as a hairdresser,
and still occasionally, if I'm
pushed, I can cut a mullet.
I do a very mean mullet.
Those were the
days they were in.
And so I did that
for a few years,
but I'd always had this
desire, if you like,
to write and to tell stories.
And it was something
that I'd always done.
If you like, I was a
bit of a raconteur.
And I remember I had this
flatmate at this time.
And she said, you
know, you're always
having these funny stories
at parties and everything.
Why don't you start
writing them down?
And I did.
She then introduced
me to a friend
of hers who was a
male journalist that
worked on "Cosmopolitan,"
kind of a seedy man.
And I suppose I was
19 at that time.
So he certainly took
me under his wing.
But he believed that I had
talent and encouraged me.
And then just through a series
of coincidental events--
the '80s was almost a very
similar time in a way to now.
There was an optimism
and an explosion
and an interest in
entrepreneurialism.
If you like, it was what's
happening in the online world
now with all these
startups and everything.
It was kind of
happening at that time
in the '80s under Thatcher.
Of course she made such a
[INAUDIBLE] of everything
that we forget that
at the very beginning,
it was quite an exciting time.
And I managed to blag my
way into women's magazines.
I remember the first time
I went into a magazine,
it was "Just Seventee," and
I wasn't much more than 17
myself.
I suppose I was about 19.
And a bit like this
next morning, I woke up,
and I thought oh my god.
I've got an
appointment with a man
who was one of my
hairdressing client's husbands
who was the features
editor on "Just Seventeen."
And I had this thing
that I had written
on my electric typewriter.
And I was going into see
him, and I just thought,
what do you wear?
What do you wear when you
go into a news magazine?
It was the '80s.
And so I put on-- in
the '80s, the fashion
was very much-- it
was like costumes.
It was all very new romantic.
And I remember i
put on-- I'll never
forget what I wore-- a
kind of a sailor dress.
It was like a sailor dress, and
then these big button earrings.
And I accessorized
it with gloves.
And I remember I went
in to see this guy,
and I was all done up with
lipstick, and the earrings,
and the high shoes,
and everything,
and this sailor dress.
And everyone in the office was
wearing jeans and t-shirts.
And this man who was probably
in his '30s at the time, which
was very middle-aged to me at
the time, he read my article,
and he thought it was great.
And he actually
commissioned on the spot,
and that was the beginning.
And then as I was
leaving, he looked up
and he said, where
are you going?
He obviously thought I was
going to Henley or something.
The minute I'd walked
into the office,
he'd obviously looked at me and
thought, what the hell has she
got on?
And I was too
embarrassed to say,
I dressed like this
especially for you."
So that was the
start of it for me.
And I started to get
my work published.
And I was so thrilled, because
I had never ever dreamt
that I would ever be able
to get anything published,
be a published writer
or be a published
journalist with no education, no
background, no English degree--
nothing, that this
had just happened,
that I was able to write
things and that people willing
to publish them.
And this seemed to
me to be miraculous.
And it still does, actually,
to this day and 30 odd years
later.
This seemed to me
very miraculous.
And so driven by that kind of
feeling that, oh my goodness,
anything can happen, I
became quite ambitious.
But not ambitious, I
don't think, in the way
that we understand it, but
almost ambitious in a way of,
goodness me.
I wonder if someone
would actually
give me a full time job?
So I applied for full time
jobs, and then someone did.
And I thought, goodness me.
What would happen if I actually
applied to be an editor?
And so I did, and then
they did make me an editor.
And so I went on like
this and ended up
becoming editor of a number of
very successful young women's
magazines.
And I suppose I wanted to talk
a bit about technology as well.
Because it was just--
one of the reasons
why I love technology
so much in my life today
is because that too seems
slightly miraculous to me,
that when I started work
in women's magazines,
I had an electric typewriter.
My parents bought me an electric
typewriter in my late teens.
Oh my god, that was just
like the most super duper
duped up Mac you could
possibly imagine at the time.
You pressed a button,
and it went pop pop.
And every time you
pressed it, it just
made this popping sound.
It was just unbelievable.
And then you'd be pop, pop, pop,
pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
And it had an
eraser ribbon on it,
so that if you wanted to erase
something, there was a Tipp-ex.
You had to buy these
Tipp-ex erasers.
And you'd be nearly
making mistakes just
to see this happen.
So we went on from that then
to these Amstrad computers.
I wrote a book, actually.
I was commissioned to write
a book for teenage girls
at that time, and I wrote
a book on the Amstrad.
And the technology changed
so quickly at that time
that, actually, I couldn't
get the book off the Amstrad
onto a printer.
Because by the time I'd
finished writing the book,
the Amstrads were
so delete and Macs
had come in that I had
to ring around Europe
to find someone that
had a printer that
could get the stuff off
this old Amstrad for me.
And then I think when
I was in the early '90s
then, I remember editing
"Just Seventeen" magazine.
And then overnight, Apple
came in and just completely
transformed the
whole print industry.
And we went from one
sticking text down
on bits of paper, which
just seems incredible.
It seems incredible to me now
that when I started my career
we were literally--
we were typing stuff
up on electric typewriters.
It was incredibly complicated.
Publishing was an incredibly
complicated business,
because there were so many
different departments.
You had the sticking
down the words
on bits of paper department.
And then you had the
checking that the words
were correct department.
And then you had the department
for making them all fit.
And then you had the
department for scanning them.
And it was just incredible.
So I feel very lucky that I saw
that period of time happening.
So all the time that I was
working in women's magazines,
there came a point where
I felt I was moving
further and further away.
Even though I was
very successful,
and I was winning awards,
and everyone thought
I was marvelous, and the
magazines were selling,
there came a point where I
just thought I'm not really,
really doing what I
really, really want to do
and what I really set out to
do, which was to write stuff
down and have people read it.
And I was managing people,
and negotiating salaries,
and coming up with
marketing ideas, and all
of this other stuff that just
didn't seem to have anything
to do with who I was anymore.
And so I left all of that
behind and moved to Ireland.
And everyone, all of
my contemporaries,
were university horrified.
It was like I was totally moving
to the deep south boondocks,
which I was.
I mean, literally, when
I moved over to Ireland,
I went from working in the
equivalent company-- it
was called EMAP Metro, and
it was the equivalent company
of Google.
Everyone wanted to work there.
They published "Just
Seventeen," and "Smash
it Hits," and "Empire
Magazine."-- all very cool.
I went from that to working in a
little dingy basement in Dublin
with two people and
literally no computers--
sticking things back down
onto bits of paper again.
So I began a new
phase of my life,
and it took me a
few years to settle,
but what I had done was, I
suppose, made a decision,
made a global decision, that
I wanted to commit myself
back into myself
as a writer, which
had been my original intention.
And so over the next 10
years, that's what I did.
I worked on women's
magazines in Ireland, which
was great, quite successful.
And I earned a living,
and it was fine.
But it wasn't like London.
And I continued to
write in my spare time.
And for a long
time I wrote books,
and I wrote short stories.
And I sent them off
to competitions,
and I got lots and lots and lots
and lots and lots of rejection.
And eventually, after a long
time, I got a book deal.
And the book deal that
I got was very good.
And it was based on me writing
these high octane comedy novels
under the name Morag Prunty.
And that was around the 2000.
So I wrote four of those
books, and they were fine.
They did very well
and everything.
And then I just took one step
further away from civilization.
I moved from Dublin.
I had a son.
And after he was born,
I moved from Dublin
down to the west coast of
Ireland, down to the country
and bought a house,
which I still live in,
which is a nice old house.
And it's on the sea.
There's my house, my
front garden, the sea,
which is great.
And I started to write very
different types of books.
I started to write books that
were more romantic, a bit more
serious, a little
bit less high octane.
And that was it.
My publishers changed my name,
because there was a turnaround.
There was such a
dramatic change in style.
They changed my name
from Morag Prunty
to Kate Kerrigan, which is
also my mother-in-law's name.
So my married name and my
mother-in-law's first name.
So she's very
pleased about that.
And when and that's it.
That's 25 minutes.
Does anyone want to ask
me any questions or?
AUDIENCE: What was is
it like changing your--
to me, that's such a
stark change in identity.
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You're
writing, and maybe it
allowed you more
creative freedom
to then take a different
approach in your writing.
Was that something
that you embraced?
Because it sounds like
they came to you and said,
we're changing your name.
Oh, Ok.
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah, yeah.
Well, it is.
I think what I'm
always searching
for as a writer, always,
is the truth-- it's
the kernel and
the truth in life,
and about what it
is to be human,
and about what is to be a woman.
So that's really what every
book that I write is about.
That's what's at
the heart of it.
And what happens is you
have the heart of a book,
and then you come at it
from different angles.
Like in this book,
I've come at it
from the angle of what
we wear and fashion,
which always appears,
and has always
appeared to me the most--
I suppose because I worked
in fashion magazines as
well-- that we wear in fashion
and everything seems to be, in
a sense, the least important
thing.
And I've always thought
of it as being the least
important thing.
And with this book,
I've decided, well,
actually maybe it's a
very important thing.
What would it be if it was
a very important thing?
If what we wear
was very important?
If the clothes that we
wore carried something
of the essence of who we were?
And so in a sense, it
doesn't matter to me
what the name of the person
is that's writing the book.
What's important
to me is getting
to the truth of the story,
and also the story itself,
the kernel of the book,
and the point of it.
And as a writer, one of the
things that I am constantly
moving towards is separating
myself from the story as much
as I possibly can.
Writing is a very
personal thing,
and you do put of
yourself in it.
But one of the greatest mistakes
that you can make as a writer
is to be authorial,
which is to let a story
or let a character be affected
by who you are in a way,
and what you think of them.
I realized this a number of
years ago when I wrote a book.
People were coming
back and saying
that my main protagonists
were quite bitchy.
They were always quite
bitchy women with issues.
And I realized that
what I was doing
is I was putting
too much of myself
into my central characters.
And you're always much
harder on yourself
than you are on other people.
So because my characters were
carrying so much of who I was,
I was making them a little
bit bitchy, and a little bit
snipey, and a little bit smart.
And they weren't as likable.
Because-- I don't
know, but I know
that, I think, as women, for me,
I have an essential insecurity
just from being a woman
that I carry around with me.
And that was infecting the
characters in my books.
So I wasn't able to be as
authentic with the characters.
I was being more true
to myself than I was
to the characters in the book.
So separating who I am
from the actual characters.
And it's quite interesting,
because Morag Prunty
is my own name, and Kate
Kerrigan is my pen name.
And Morag Prunty's
actually a great name,
and Kate Kerrigan is actually
a really boring name.
But it actually doesn't have
any effect on me one way
or another.
Because as long as
the book gets written,
and as long as many people as
possible buy it and read it,
then that's all that matters.
AUDIENCE: What I find
fascinating is that everyday I
meet so many people just trying
to discover what they want
to do with their lives, and
even if they discover it,
trying to get that.
And when I see
you, I see someone
that is successful and also
doing with she likes to do.
And after listening to
your story, [INAUDIBLE]
but what would you
say was the secret?
Just luck?
Being in the right place?
Being open to opportunities?
I mean, what would be
your-- especially also
because you're a woman.
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I think it's much
more inspiring because of that.
KATE KERRIGAN: One
interesting thing
actually that
somebody said to me,
it was a quote form a writer,
which I thought was fantastic,
is what is the single most
important thing that you need
to become a successful writer?
And I can't remember
who said it,
but this person turned around
and said, low overheads.
Do you know?
And actually that's true.
I think that if you want to--
I am doing what I really,
really want to do, but
you take risks with that.
You have to take risks.
And it's not the risk of I'm
going to step into the abyss
and I'm going to believe that
somebody is going to lift me up
and I'm going to
soar into the sky.
You have to think, well, if
I step off into the abyss,
do you know what?
I might fall down for a bit,
and I might be hanging off
a cliff for awhile.
Do you know what I mean?
And maybe somebody
will come and save me.
And maybe they won't.
You have to be prepared
for it to work,
but you also have to be
prepared for it not to work.
And you have to be
prepared to be happy for it
not to work and be OK with that
just to do what you want to do.
I moved to Ireland
in '91 or '92,
and I left absolutely at the
height of a really amazing
career in publishing.
It really was.
It was like being
a star at Google.
At that time, it
was the equivalent.
And I went over to
Ireland, and I thought,
I'm going to write poems.
And I was following-- I
had a boyfriend as well,
and he was Irish.
And I was going to
write, and I thought
everything would be good.
And after about a year, I was
so miserable I thought, shit.
What have I done?
Do you know?
I've got no money.
I'm working in a
smelly basement.
These people don't even
know how to use a Mac.
This is horrendous, and
I've got absolutely no time
to do my writing or
anything like that.
What have I done?
And I applied for
a job in the UK.
I thought, right, well,
it's only been a year.
I'm going to come back.
And I applied for a job in
the UK, and I got blocked,
and I didn't get to interview.
It was like a punishment
for having left or whatever.
But that's when I
made a decision.
I thought I'm here now.
I came here for a reason.
This is what I wanted to
do, and it will work out.
Being a writer has been a very
interesting journey for me,
because I had 10 years of
writing with no success.
Then I got a huge book deal,
and this is, oh my god.
This was the Celtic
Tiger years in Ireland
and a huge boom time
for publishing here.
And I thought, this is it now.
I've got this big deal.
I have hit the big time.
But it didn't work
out like that.
I went up.
I went down.
Every year you never know
how any book is going to do.
You're always going to be
an international bestseller
until you're not.
Do you know?
So you have to be prepared
to go along with that.
But all through that
with absolute focus--
I've just remained
absolutely focused
since making that decision.
And because of that I
have a really nice life.
I would say that I have
a nicer life than many
of my contemporaries that stayed
in London, and did very well,
and earned a lot of money.
I have a lovely house
in a beautiful place,
and I'm doing what I want to do,
and I have the time to do it.
So I think that's
it, and I think
if there's one thing that
people have said about me,
it's that once I put my mind
to something I just focus.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I actually grew up
collecting magazines.
KATE KERRIGAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I grew up
collecting magazines.
KATE KERRIGAN: Oh, did you?
Oh, you're much
younger than your--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so [INAUDIBLE]
publishing industry.
So how do you think
it's changed or hasn't?
Magazine collecting or
magazines in general
in terms of its sales
since obviously it's
gone digital now?
How do you feel [INAUDIBLE]
KATE KERRIGAN: No, I
don't think-- I mean,
I don't think I
would, but I do think
it's a very interesting
time in publishing,
and I do think that
what's happened
is "Just Seventeen"
has folded, "Ms."
All the only young women's
magazines now have folded.
They've gone.
Everyone is getting
that information online.
But what's become
very big is comics.
And that's really the
boys collecting comics.
So I think there is actually
room in the market for a girl
equivalent for that.
Comics and graphic
novels are huge.
It's almost the role of
magazines has played.
Girls can get their
advice now, all the
stuff that they got
the magazines, which
was personal advice, agony
aunts, makeup, fashion--
all of that, they can
get all of that online,
and they'd be right to.
But there's an
increase in book sales,
interestingly,
among young people.
One of the trends that
I've found interesting
is that young people
now in their teens
are not using Kindles as
much as our generation
for the very reason that
they can't collect magazines
anymore, because
magazines don't exist.
They also can't collect
albums, records, CDs.
All of those things
don't exists.
So what they're doing is
they're buying books and comics.
So I think if someone can
come up with something
that teenage girls
can collect again,
that would be interesting.
But I think my
generation of women,
of people, who worked in
magazines, one of the things
that I find interesting
is that if you go online
and you Google "Just Seventeen,"
nothing comes out-- nothing.
It's like we never existed.
And I think it's because
mine was that crossover
generation that literally
went from magazines
and then we just went, ugh, and
straight into new technology.
And so there hasn't been
any preservation of them.
Whereas if you look up magazines
from the 1950s and 1960s,
loads come up online.
They've all been preserved.
So if you have a "Just
Seventeen" collection--
AUDIENCE: I actually got
rid of all my [INAUDIBLE]
"Just Seventeen" probably
about seven years ago.
KATE KERRIGAN: Aww.
AUDIENCE: But I
kept the ones that
had my favorite [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I've [INAUDIBLE].
We went to school together.
So I'm going to ask the question
that I know everybody really
wants to know.
And that is, did you
snog Robbie Williams?
KATE KERRIGAN: No, I didn't.
AUDIENCE: Did you
snog any of them?
KATE KERRIGAN: No.
But I did get asked out
continuously and quite
consistently by Jason, who--
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
KATE KERRIGAN: Close your
ears son, who is, to my mind,
still the best looking
member of "Take That."
But he had terrible
acne all down his back.
AUDIENCE: How do you know that?
KATE KERRIGAN: Because I was
once photographed in bed--
I once did a-- when
they started out,
they all wore-- they had this
horrible seedy little manager
who was trying to push them
towards the gay market,
and he used to dress them
up in all this S&M gear.
You might remember that.
I did "In Bed with Auntie
Morag" with "Take That"
at the time of Madonna.
And I got into bed with them
in a Winceyette nightie,
and they were all in the nip.
But he did ask me out a few
times, but I never went.
Because, actually, I thought
they were all years younger
than me, but then I
subsequently found out
that they weren't, that
they lied about their age.
So I could have ended up-- I say
it to my husband all the time,
don't I?
I could have been married
to Jason from "Take That,"
but instead I'm married to you.
Mhm?
AUDIENCE: Just asking
about your family,
it seems that you have a
strong support network.
And with those ups
and downs, I don't
know how I would be able to
cope with 10 years of putting
my heart and soul into writing
and waiting for that big break.
What advice, or how was it for
you having that kind of support
to get you through that?
Or was it that you were
finding your way at that time?
KATE KERRIGAN: Well, I
had that, but I think
it's just dogged determination.
And also, because if
you're a creative person,
people have that thing that
I'm going to become a writer,
and I'm going to sell books.
It's not career choice.
it's like a vocations.
If you're an artist
or if you're a writer,
it's like a vocation thing.
So you have to do it because
you really love doing it.
And so yeah, you
do get the support,
but you just think, well,
what else and I going to do?
I'm not going to stop writing
because someone's rejected me.
And maybe I am crap, but I'm
still going to keep doing it.
And you always, always
try to get better.
I've had a really
interesting experience
in the last couple of years.
When I was writing this
book I got a new editor,
this woman called
Rosie De Courcy.
And she's an older woman.
I don't how old she is, but she
edited Maeve Binchy and Penny
Vincenzi, and she's edited
some really amazing writers.
It was for the new
publishing house,
and before I submitted this
book to them for publication,
it had been through
three complete rewrites
with a freelance editors.
I suppose I'd worked on it
flatout for about 18 months
before she got it.
And her publishing, the
CEO at the publishing house
was very excited.
They bought the book.
This is amazing.
We love Kate.
There was a big change,
new publishing house,
and everything's just fantastic.
And then I went out
for lunch with Rosie,
who was going to be my
big point of contact.
And I sat down,
and we had lunch.
And everything was nice.
And then we talked about-- and
she didn't mention the book,
so I said what do you think?
What do you think
of "The Dress?"
What's the story?
And she said, well, it's
certainly got potential.
I can see that there's
something in there.
And I thought, what?
I've had-- I don't know-- 12
books published at this stage.
And so for the last
year, I've been
working with this woman, who
has just been tearing it up,
start again, tear
it up, start again.
And of all of my years of being
rejected, rejected, rejected,
have all brought
me to a place where
I can work with an editor
of that caliber who
is so determined to get
the book up to the point
where it can reach its
absolute full potential.
And I think the thing about
being a successful writer
or a successful artist is having
enough self-belief and enough
detachment from what
other people think of you.
And the desire to create
has to be much, much bigger
than the desire for what
that creation my end up with.
Do you understand?
If you create
something wonderful,
people will think you're great,
and they'll give you money.
And loads of people will buy it
If you create something great.
But all of that has two
mean absolutely nothing
when you're doing it.
You have to be completely
separate from it.
And so the editing
process for this book
was unbelievably
arduous, but I was
able, because of those
early rejections,
to just say, well,
look, this woman,
literally, all she's doing
is focusing on what can we
do to make this book better?
And I'm focusing on what can
we do to make this book better.
And at no point is she
thinking she can't do it.
When you're creating
something, you just
keep going until it's right.
And you do put your
heart and soul into it,
but you're not tough--
AUDIENCE: But are you happy
with the final product?
KATE KERRIGAN: Oh my god, yeah.
But I didn't think I would be.
And at every point, it's
been incredible working
with this new editor.
Because what she was
able to do is she
was able to take
what I had written,
and hone it down so
that it's more the book
that I originally wanted
to write than the book
that I did originally write.
She's so skilled that
she was able to--
Because you have the
kernel, the core of an idea.
And then you start
dressing it up.
And you bring in
different characters,
and then you think, well,
I need a modern storyline,
so I do this character.
And then she needs a boyfriend,
so I'll bring him in.
And you dress it up to
make the story work.
But sometimes the dressing
that you put on it isn't right.
And you have to trust the
people that you're working with,
and you have to trust
your own ability.
Like, at the end of
this book, there's
two-- it's a dual storyline.
So part of the book is set
in the 1950s in America.
And that story really, the
characters and everything,
they worked.
And then there's a
modern storyline,
which is a young fashion
blogger and her best
friend and her love interest.
And the young fashion blogger
and her love interest,
who are two key elements
in the book, both of them
were completely
different people when
I started writing the book.
And we just killed both of them
after having rewritten them
both about five times.
But in the end, they
just got killed off.
And people find
that unfathomable.
How could you come
up with a character?
But there was one character
in the original book.
I called him Liam.
He had a history.
He had a family.
He was good looking.
He had a whole thing
going on with him.
I could have written a
whole book about him.
I developed him so much.
And then one day I
was talking to Rosie,
and I just said, you know?
I'm just gone off him.
I don't like him anymore.
And I just killed him
and invented someone new.
And the new guy that I invented,
light just went-- like this.
And he's just much better.
But the book could
have gone out.
It could have gone out
without all of those edits.
They weren't-- but it's just
that now it's just much, much,
much, much better than it was.
But even things
like, you sit down,
and it's bits that-- even
after all these years,
I could spend a morning
writing a paragraph,
really honing it and
making it beautiful.
And then Rosie would
just go-- superfluous.
But it's the same
in everyone's job.
That must happen to
you guys all the time.
I've had this really,
really great idea.
It's really fantastic.
And then someone just
comes along and goes-- no.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a
bit about your writing?
Do you write every day?
Are you--
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Strict with
yourself about writing?
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah, because
I mean, you can go for-- yeah.
I have to be really,
really disciplined.
So I have to write every day.
But a part of that as
well is needs must.
Because I have to
write a book a year.
So if you write a book a year,
you've got to write a bit of it
every day.
And I also have a
weekly newspaper column,
and at the moment, I'm doing
a lot of publicity stuff,
so I'm doing a lot of journalism
and that kind of stuff as well.
So I do.
I have to write every
single day, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it
helpful-- [INAUDIBLE].
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
There is that.
I think it's more theoretical.
I mean, how I work the best
as a writer is locked away
completely on my own
in 24 hour stints.
So on occasion I go off, and
I go to hermitages and places
like that.
And I might go
away for two weeks.
That's the longest I've
done without speaking
to another human being.
And I absolutely love that.
But I very rarely get to do it.
I might get another two weeks
stint next year very rarely.
But it's funny.
I was talking to
a friend of mine,
I'm very friendly with some of
the Irish writers like Cecilia
Ahern, you know Cecilia Ahern?
And we had lunch
a few weeks ago,
and she was telling me that
she was watching something
on the television.
And it was some movie.
And there was this
person in a jail cell.
They were locked in a jail
cell, and they were sitting over
at the window with a bucket
for peeing in the corner.
And they were just sitting there
writing with a pen and paper.
And she said she and her husband
were sitting watching that,
and he just turned to her
and he went, you'd love that,
wouldn't you?
And she went, yeah.
That's what we all want, really.
That's it.
That's all I want to do.
And I don't get to do it.
I mean, I couldn't
live my life like that,
because I'd go bonkers.
But I do dream about it.
I'm trying to keep myself
alive as long as I can
so that when I'm older
that's how I'll live,
and that's what
I'll be able to do.
It's great.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Do you get distracted
by the internet though?
In terms of research, do you--
KATE KERRIGAN: I
am so addicted to--
AUDIENCE: If I was
locked away in a room,
I would be like, I'll
just write a paragraph.
And then oh, I'll just
check this article online.
KATE KERRIGAN: Online, terrible.
I use anti-social a lot.
I'm absolutely and completely
addicted to social media.
I've actually got RSI.
I suffer from repetitive strain
injury and also arthritis.
So in the last few months, I've
had to completely transform
my writing practice so that
I don't have the internet
on my phone anymore.
I'm getting an old lady phone.
I've had to cut myself off a lot
from social media on the phone.
And I'm now using voice
recognition technology
to write, which is strange.
But again, it's part
of the determination.
Because not being able to write,
for me, in the last few months,
has been them
cripplingly painful,
emotionally for me,
to be losing touch
with the actual physical pop,
pop, pop of the keyboard.
And every time I sat down at
the keyboard, I'd be in pain.
It was just some kind of
horrible cosmic punishment.
But I've had to master the
voice recognition, which
has been really awful.
But you just have to do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] do you do
a lot of research at the front
once you've had an
idea, like the 1950s?
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or do you write
a bit and go think, oh, I
should actually look at the
historical truth of this.
KATE KERRIGAN:
Well, a bit of both.
Yeah, and I find that actually
researching as I go along
is better.
Because otherwise what happens
is-- the most important thing,
for me, is emotional
resonance in a book.
But when you research stuff
and you find it interesting,
that then becomes fascinating.
And so what you want to do
is, like with this book,
you just want to keep reading
off lists and describing
dresses, and reading off
lists of interesting designers
that no one's heard
of of that time.
And you become bogged
down in all of that stuff
and you lose the core of it.
So I tend now to
do less research.
And also, I did a huge
amount of research on a book
last year about organic
and city farming.
And I did a huge
amount of research.
I went to New York, and I
did real research on it.
And my editor just went,
no, I don't like that.
And so it's just gone.
Poof.
Finished.
So I tend to do
it as I go along.
Shall I read you just
a five minute passage?
Yeah?
I'll see if I can--
I'm just going
to read the beginning
bit a bit, which
is the prologue, which has
no dresses in it whatsoever.
Oh my god.
I can't see anything.
Thanks, but I was just
getting my glasses out.
No, stop.
You won't find them.
SARAH: I have.
KATE KERRIGAN: Oh, good woman.
Ireland 1935-- the
schoolmaster have found the boy
collapsed against a stone
wall at the side of the road.
His nose was smashed and
bloody, and his right eye so
swollen that he could
barely see out of it.
Dear God, Francis,
what happened to you?
The boy looked at
him and shrugged.
His eyes were defiant, angry.
Your father?
John Conlon held out his
hand to help the child up,
but Francis waved him go
away and forced himself
to stand alone.
His legs were shaking.
He had taken some
battering that morning.
His father had
caught him unawares
and dragged him from the bed.
To stop himself from crying,
Francis reminded myself
that he had fought
back and given
his father as good as he'd got.
It was the first time he'd
stood up to his father,
and that was how Francis knew
it was time for him to leave.
The last thing Francis wanted
was his teacher's pity.
He was a man of 15.
We could look after himself now.
John held out a
handkerchief, and he took it.
I'm leaving anyway, he
said, wincing slightly
as he put the cotton square
up to his nose to stem
the flow of fresh blood.
I'm going to America.
John Conlon leaned against
the wall with his pupil.
He had taught
Fitzpatrick from when
he was five until last year.
His mother had died, and
his younger brother Joe
had been put in with the nuns.
So Francis was left alone in
the house with his brutal pig
of a father.
The area they belonged
to was broad and remote,
a vast hinterland
of bog and mountain.
It was a place where a man could
hide his wife and children away
from the eyes of
the world, but not
those of a prying
Irish schoolmaster.
John Conlon made it
his business to know
every child in the
area, and managed
to persuade most of the
parents to leave them
in school until they
could read and write.
Francis had been with
him until he was 13,
but had left then to stay at
home to nurse his sick mother.
Now she was dead,
and the baby had
been taken away, so there was
nothing left for him at home.
He was a bright young
man, and John believed
he could have a future.
However, with a father like
that, he never stood a chance.
America, that's a long
way off, said John.
Francis glowered at him.
He could feel self
starting to crack.
He'd no idea how he
was going to get there,
but his mother had a
brother in New York.
And before she
died, she gave him
a letter saying he would
secure Francis a job
if he could get
himself to America.
The only thing Francis knew for
certain was that he was never
going back home, not ever.
I'm not going to
sit here and read
through the whole bloody book,
because you'd just-- shall
I read another little bit?
although we've only
got five minutes.
Anyone else want
to ask me anything?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KATE KERRIGAN: Read a bit more.
AUDIENCE: I was
going to say, do you
think your career before you
become a writer as you are now
has helped with the writing?
Or if you could go back
again, would you just
go straight into writing
without having that career?
KATE KERRIGAN: Oh no.
I think in any
form of creativity
the best thing that you
can do is experience life.
And in fact, when I have
young interns coming in to me,
I always say to them, don't
study literature in school.
If you want to become a
writer, if you're very clever,
go and study law.
Because I think that's a--
law is all about language.
But no.
I think the only
way to-- I certainly
do not regret the years I
spent writing journalism
either, and working with words.
Alan Sillitoe once said quantity
produces quality eventually.
And it's true.
I think you have to do it.
And the years in hairdressing
were the best experience
I ever had.
I mean, by the time most
of my contemporaries
were leaving university, I
was able to do things that-- I
had so many life skills.
I was able to talk to people,
and communicate with people,
and blag my way into
jobs, and operate a till,
and have all kinds of
useful skills from having
left school very young.
I do regret not having had
an education insofar as there
are absolute gaps in my
basic knowledge, even
from primary school.
I mean, when my husband and son
are sitting doing his homework,
things like geography.
And they're going,
where's Russia?
And I'm going can you show me?
So there are gaps and
books that I haven't read.
And I do feel
personally insecure.
Mary will attest to the fact
that I don't have a third level
education.
Personally, I do have issues
around that sometimes.
But no.
I think that I would never,
ever regret going back,
or want to go back
and change anything
that I did or didn't do.
And I would encourage anyone,
if there's something that you
want to do, just go and do it.
Because you can't-- God, the
times that are in it now,
I often look at my mother with
a her big school teacher pension
and all that kind of
stuff, and think, oh,
you know I could have--
But as a writer, sometimes
I need to have a day job
and sometimes I don't.
But I think it's always
important, whatever
your day job is, to push
into whatever you want to do.
That's it then.
Is that it?
Or was there?
All right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: We're all
listening intently.
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: What advice do
you have for new writers?
Obviously, I'm going to assume
when you were starting out,
it would be send
manuscripts man to agents.
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], what kind
of tips do you have for anyone
who's--
KATE KERRIGAN: I think
the most important thing
is to write every
day and to not be--
I think just to write every
day and to keep doing it.
It's good to go the
conventional route,
find an agent-- all that kind of
stuff, a good publishing house,
I think.
But there are so many different
routes now for writers,
and self-publishing is
definitely one of them.
There's a very, very
important synergy
between writing, and
technology, and marketing,
and what you guys do.
I mean, the most important
person in my publishing house
right now is the girl that
does all of the online sales.
And it's called what?
Was it called algorithms?
What is that stuff called?
Is it algorithms or?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KATE KERRIGAN: Meta-- metadata.
I've no idea what it is,
but I know that it exists.
So I'm very impressed at myself.
But metadata.
All of that managing metadata
and all that kind of stuff--
that's all become an incredibly
important part of publishing.
And it's difficult for
writers, because you
write books, but really what
you want is you want them read.
You want people to
actually read them.
And getting people
to read the books,
I mean, now that's
just all becoming
increasingly important.
They're the heroes of our time.
AUDIENCE: So everyone, you
know what you need to do.
Write a blog or
whatever, but also
make sure you
address [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, a
question about blogging.
Have you ever blogged, or do
you encourage blogging, or?
KATE KERRIGAN: I do
encourage blogging.
I think it's great.
And I think one of the
great things about blogging
is that the level of
communication that there
is between bloggers, and
particularly book bloggers
and reviewers and
all that, of people
that are passionate
about books, now there's
a fantastic blogging
community out there.
I do think, again, finding
a market for blogging
is the difficult thing.
But I definitely encourage
it, because otherwise you're
writing a diary into
a piece of paper.
Blogging is the
new diary, really.
AUDIENCE: Also vlogging
on YouTube [INAUDIBLE]
would be like the YouTube
stars that now [INAUDIBLE]
as well as actual doing it,
as in your voice recognition
thing, they're actually
vlogging as a form of diary.
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that's
their version of writing.
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah.
Yeah, that's
interesting as well.
I--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KATE KERRIGAN: Yeah, the YouTube
thing and the whole vlogging
thing is really interesting.
It's just so
difficult when you're
coming in from the outside
to know where to begin
accessing the good vloggers.
Do you know?
But yeah, it is all changing.
And voice recognition
technology,
I think that's going to come
through for a lot of people
as well.
There's very, very
few writers using it.
Terry Pratchett
used it, but I can't
find any professional writers
that do it, apart from me.
But it has been very, very good.
I think it's important
with vlogging
and with doing anything with
the voice to actually see
it written down afterwards.
Because the work that I'm
doing at the moment, I think,
is actually an improvement on
the first draft of my written
drafts, but only because
when you vlog something,
when you write something down
with the voice recognition
technology, you need
to go back and correct
it a couple of times.
So I think it's
important that people
don't lose that relationship
with the actual written word.
Because that's only way
to make writing thoughtful
is to go back and edit it.
AUDIENCE: Do you worry these
days, like with texting, kids
all write like that naturally.
So you feel like we have to keep
hold of the English language
somehow and keep [INAUDIBLE]
correct rather than this.
And it's great to just
get your voice out there,
but then you also
don't want to lose
that proper English
language over time.
KATE KERRIGAN: But
that's texting.
It's a different thing as well.
Because it has got
that brevity to it.
When you're writing
using voice recognition,
you put in all the
punctuation, and my punctuation
has actually improved.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
KATE KERRIGAN: Oh yeah.
It's improved totally
overnight, because you
have to think about it.
Because you use
the natural pauses,
and you use all the
natural, you know?
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Thank you.
KATE KERRIGAN: Now,
are we going to finish?
I could sit here all
afternoon, frankly!
SARAH: Thank you so
much for joining us.
KATE KERRIGAN: Not at all.
Thank you.